in the early years of the North American
League Championship Series players and
organizations banded together to
legitimize competitive gaming as a
mainstream spectacle now the NA LCS is
big business it costs millions to feel
the team on that stage and more than
ever the pressure is on players to
perform rosters are constantly in flux
as teams import international talent in
the pursuit of winning and na LCS
championship organizations need
franchise players that they can build an
identity and culture around a player to
lead their team for years to come
a player who won't waver when a new
patch drops or new players are inserted
into the starting lineup a player that
they can count on to hold a team
together a player like sneaky what the
[ __ ] is a professional made streamer
here so much pressure put on cloud nine
they lose to GA
Oh W yes high school by and that that is
something that is not that will blast
emperor of evil and will probably get in
early
[Applause]
Zachery sneaky Scuderi was born in
Winter Springs Florida and played
competitive World of Warcraft before
League of Legends was released I grew up
in Orlando before I moved out to
California to pursue my career my
friends like gum into League we kind of
just played all the games together we
started off with Wow which got us into
dota and that's how I started with
here's a new earth and moved into League
legend to do that Sneaky started his
competitive law career in 2012 with
absolute gaming and like a lot of small
tournament teams from that era they only
lasted about four months together Sneaky
then started his own team called pulse
gaming with kenick onion bagel Kevin and
support daddy pulse failed to qualify
for the 2013 LCS summer promotional
tournaments at the MLG and IPL qualifier
events they competed in and as the team
constantly shuffled their roster Sneaky
began to lose confidence and their
ability to make it to the LCS it's
actually really saddening Lee's than
that because you actually realize that
you're not very good as a team I
remember a preparation was like all
right go look up there's these guys
silic use whatever right let's go
nothing past that there was no notebook
to write down all the pict bands like
what our plan is it was just pick
whatever you feel like
basically so in April 2013 Sneaky joined
quanta gaming Quantic had previously
played under the cloud9 banner without
Sneaky during the promotional tournament
for the inaugural LCS split in spring
2013 but were subsequently dropped by
the organization after they failed to
qualify the new sneaky empowered Quantic
lineup which also featured high balls
meteos and lemonnation managed to
qualify for the LCS summer 2013 split
and rejoined the cloud9 organization the
classic c9 roster that became one of the
cornerstones of the LCS and paved the
way for the macro gameplay in north
america we know today was
and they were the most impressive team
in the promotion tournament including
dignitas and CLG who had been demoted
there they steamrolled complexity three
games to none to earn their spot in the
LCS foul 9 was nothing short of dominant
in their first LCS split the team posted
a 25 and 3 record during the regular
season and rolled through the playoffs
without dropping a single match that
works together and likes each other that
is the best team to this day that record
still puts 2013 c9 as one of the most
dominant teams in na LCS history during
that first split sneaky left his mark on
the league he led all ad carry's with
the six point nine six kDa
and cleaned up on Ashe with which he
posted a whopping 11 and OH record
equalizer will be able to go across the
front they lay up down into three
members the slicing bounce tough to
follow they thought they could get the
dragon but it cost them their lives in
the fight not coming out of this one
alive toaster no link is gonna be the
next one that carries art out
that's why car dad loves the ash so much
cloud 9 qualified for the season 3 World
Championship but despite earning a
first-round bye
c9 were eliminated by the tournament's
top EU cc9 and sneaky continued their
dominance into 2014 where they once
again won the split and sneaky once
again sat atop the KD a leaderboard not
just for ADC but across all five
positions when you look at the numbers
you can make a case for sneaky being na
zest ADC in almost any LCS split he's
played in yes
he's always been top-tier North America
Navy carry sneaky was so consistent for
this team he's he shows up every single
day much like c9 he's the model of
consistency c9 and sneaky seem to
understand macro play much quicker than
the rest of the league and sneaky
credits a lot of their success to this
words on both sides of the jungle they
get to make whatever moves they want
they have that sort of map hack they can
make every decision correctly because
they can see every single move that
curse are trying to make they were able
to play as a team all over the map and
use highs shotcalling and their overall
game knowledge to play around sneaky and
snowball games
come from Hyatt to three versus four a
tubers it's random battles earned extent
and fights coming through one for once I
got that would Rock
[Music]
he'll stayin alive though his watch and
he's gonna fall stinking cutting back
away from it special special between
splits and 2014 c9 attended the
International all-star event without
their mid laner hai who was sidelined
with a collapsed lung they went three
and one in the group stage only losing
to fakers SK Telecom
they would advance through groups where
they were dispatched by one of the
Chinese representatives oMG game cloud9
put any on the map making it clear that
the region should not be overlooked
internationally in summer 2014 sneaky
and cloud 9 were met with real
competition for the first time since
they joined the LCS more than ever like
cloud nine like may not be the first
place team seal Gees looking very strong
you also don't know like lmq how good
are they how bad are they yeah I think
the team that has benefited the most
News well so changes to cement it was
clear that the league was shifting as
organisations were looking to improve
their results by importing players and
shuffling their rosters but c9 ever the
model of consistency still fielded the
same roster as their inaugural splint
cloud 9 finished the split tied for
first place with lmq an all Chinese
imported roster they then lost the
summer finals to Team solomid who were
playing their second split with European
superstar appears
2014 North American
champions they have finally done
they have defeated cloud died in the
playoff after the summer finals it was
time for worlds where cloud 9 would make
North American history cloud 9 went 4
and 2 in their worlds group stage and
met Korean powerhouse Samsung blue in
the quarterfinals
[Music]
ancestry will be finished up the focus
and move through to the semi-finals
cloud9 lost that series 3 to 1 but
became the first na team in the LCS era
to take a game off of a Korean team at a
major international tournament sneaky
was a driving force in the series
showing that he could compete alongside
the game's best ad carry's
cloud9
road the momentum they have from worlds
into another postseason event at IEM San
Jose where cloud nine and particularly
sneaky shine
[Music]
understand it's a double for sneaking a
little cloud nine hi love we'll go look
sleek he finally told me too many going
down he's keeping them up a bogey by
menials it doesn't get answered man it
was well with the damage onto his
massive sleek he will get the first one
Keke's his low he was hooked in there by
eleven nation and that means a two for
two right now at least boats leaky still
alive put blocks down Perot
they're bursts of success on the
international stage aside the transition
between summer 2014 and the 2015 LCS
season was certainly a changing of the
guard for sneaky and cloud 9 they simply
weren't the best anymore
team solomid had knocked them off their
pedestal and they were going to let them
take it back anytime soon cloud 9 went
12 and 6 in the 2015 spring split
rebounding after a shaky first two weeks
they went into the playoffs with a
first-round bye
and were 2nd place overall behind TSM
but once again they weren't able to
defeat bjergsen and company in the
finals the 2015 North American League of
Legends Championship Series spring split
champions
despite the veil of dominance being
lifted from his team sneaky had stayed
on course he continued to show that he
was the ADC to beat in the TSM and c9
rivalry
can make it through this they got it but
Clark 9 is locking them down York sit on
the outside he gets walked in with the
position reverser
how is TSM still alive in this one they
are doing everything they can but cloud
9 closes the door on that fight
sneaky once again led all 80 carries in
kDa and died less than any other bought
Lane marksman high was removed from the
mid lane prior to the summer season and
replaced by Jensen who was then known as
incarnation a young European playmaker
whose competitive lifetime ban was
recently lifted I don't think the roster
change was ever initially brought up by
any of the players I think it was just
Jack looking out for us no one really
wanted to go either our way to say hey I
think we need to change player out here
as the 2015 summer split started cloud 9
looked like a shadow of their former
self the worst trend though is cloud 9
even after beating TSM with the first
game of the split now sits and want me
three
and they shut down clown
and cloud 9 once again find themselves
at the short end of the stick here after
actually playing a strong game but not
finding the advantage that pushes them
to the wind just yet there's a lot of
growing to do for this new cloud 9 squad
with incarnation instead of hi despite
the fact that sneaky was still making
big plays in the vault lane the team
went 6 and 12
during the split their worst record ever
and missed the playoffs for the first
time in franchise history I'd say
definitely have thought a bit more about
like not being on cloud 9 just because
we're in such a bad spot right now
after the split sneaky did his best to
show that what remained of the old guard
c9 roster could still compete well I
think the only ever time that it was you
know talked about like leaving yeah that
was kind of like a riot push agenda I
never really said it it was just like
you guys are doing terribly sneaky
what would you think about you know
joining different team I'm like I mean
yeah we're like eighth place LCS right
now they played in a regional finals
gauntlet to try and secure the third any
berth in worlds that year c9 was coming
off one of their worst LCS performances
ever but the gauntlet gave them a chance
to remain a beacon for North America on
the international stage to be able to
bring it back and actually go to Worlds
would be amazing for us considering our
pretty terrible season as strange as it
sounds to call cloud nine a cinderella
story they could go on a miracle run to
secure their third consecutive
appearance at Worlds - OH
or I should say Oh - that gravity put
them in two go three two
versus gravity in the first call it game
of the North American summer split
cloud9 are moving on to take on impulse
have to give up the bass they give up
the game they give up the series cloud9
get through a first sweep and they're
gonna face teamliquid it's gonna be the
Nexus that's gonna be the game that's
gonna be a trip
not only did c9 win the regional
qualifier and get a spot at Worlds
but sneaky dominated there's the shot
there's the show there's a second one
it's a 30-minute window killed
everybody's in sneaky goes for more he's
building it's a triple kill there's the
key takes is dead
[Music]
to the surprise of most cloud9
dominated the first week of world's
going a perfect three-and-oh against
some of the best teams in the world that
no one counted
completely different age queue this is
not a one to age this is a to see this
big sis gaming pick up a win against
cloud nine and now they're into the base
HQ looking for the play the mop whittle
does not matter there is no damage there
is no base left there is only victory
for a HQ one final touch on the other
side of the map it's like he's played
space jam and a HQ will be the final
team at a groupie prior to the 2016 LCS
season sea nines persistence to keep
much of their lineup together caught up
to them teams like immortals were
boasting impressive imported talent in
the likes of hooni and reignover and
just being consistent wasn't going to be
enough for c9 even their biggest rival
TSM we're making the changes necessary
to stay on top bringing in doublelift
yellowstar and spence Garen c9 made a
few changes as well to try to keep up
with the quickly shifting na LCS
lemonnation had retired and c9 added
both jungler rush and support player
bunny foo-foo to their roster bunny
split time with high in the ball Lane as
the organization was trying to reshape
the roster around sneaky well it's
definitely a different atmosphere and we
have bunny in the team because hai is
like the super shot-caller where he's
trying to always talk but when we have
buy-in team it's not necessarily a bad
thing but he's like a bit less talkative
like less commanding and then rush kind
of like takes over a little bit of the
role so it's like shared between him and
bunny the 2016 spring split was just as
lackluster as their worlds wrong they
finished third at na during the split
and lost to TSM in the playoffs again it
was at the end of this split that cloud
9 took the rebuilding plan to a new
level they shuffled around their LCS
roster with their Challenger team impact
in the top lane meteos in the jungle
Jensen was now full time in the mid lane
sneaky at 80 carry as always and bunny
foo-foo and newcomer smoothie split time
in the support role
during that year c9 matched their 12 six
record from spring making it back to the
finals for the first time in three
splits sneaky finished second behind
double lift in kDa and had an impressive
split acting as a stabilizing presence
for a roster that was just learning how
to play around each other but once again
there they were defeated by TSM
American Championship
you're looking at cloud nine right now
you can see the disappointment because
they know they had some chances in that
14 to force a game five and now if they
want to go to Worlds
they have to make it through the
regional qualifier c9 competed at Worlds
again after the season two and other
quarterfinals exit they had overhauled
the majority of their roster but still
weren't getting the championship results
they were looking for meteos left the
team and contracts was called up to fill
the hole in the jungle for spring 2017 I
think we'll be pretty ready for this
spring split it's pretty important to us
I think it's gonna be a pretty big lead
into summer and if we can perform now
which we should be able to from our
practice and it'll really help us out a
lot just as the split was set to begin
sneaky was the only member of the
original cloud9 left standing does it
feel weird thinking about that like I
mean you are the original you're the
only one left get lonely yeah I don't
love me but I definitely kind of been
think about that one more as of recently
like I was playing against media's in
scrims and we were like winning one big
Anjali hard I started feeling really
excited for media's I'm just like
honestly I'm cool
even though major changes had finally
come to one of the LCS as original
powerhouses the results were the same
this new look cloud 9 went 14 and 4 in
the regular season only to lose another
playoff final to TSM
[Applause]
[Applause]
in a lot of ways both clownin and sneaky
have followed the same enigmatic path
through their time in the LCS they're
always good always in the conversation
among na is best but it had been a while
since they sat atop the standings
cloud9 went from the shining star of the
na LCS to the league's perennial second
fiddle they rally back from a slow start
in 2017 summer to make the playoffs only
to be ousted in the quarterfinals by
Dignitas now we've recently seen their
2018 run come to an end in similar
fashion
they looked impressive for the majority
of the first half of the split but
faltered a little heading into playoffs
to finish 12 and eight Team Liquid then
knocked them out of the playoffs in the
quarterfinals for the second time in a
row double left getting the better of
sneaky once again this time in another
uniform sneaky had a solid year but it
just hasn't been good enough since as
far back as spring 2014
[Music]
throughout his career with cloud 9
sneaky stream has always been a major
part of his identity as a player just
like on the rift sneaky stream has been
consistent ever since he began his
career in the LCS it's on stream where
he garnered his reputation as a bit of a
meme sneaky is always good for a few
dozen feels good man's a week on stream
he's always laid-back and joking around
with this chat
[Music]
his streams are just like his playing
career not always making headlines not
breaking viewership records but always
they're always entertaining and always
worth your attention
[Music]
sneaky streams about three or four times
a week even during the season while
comparable names like double after
Burton can be a little more streaky
sometimes taking weeks off at a time
sneaky recently made headlines for his
on stream luxe cosplay a long-term sub
goal that drew attention from all over
the eSports world streaming often allows
us a little look into the lives of pro
players whether it's B rickson's laser
focus or double lifts constant trash
talk the biggest takeaway from what you
see from sneaky on stream is the kind of
unshakeable attitude he exudes on the
LCS stage no matter just how much his
chat is flaming him he's always got the
same nonchalant attitude and then hits
them with a feels bad man we've arrived
in an LCS world where organizations are
franchised for the long term in this new
world sneaky is the image of the
consummate professional but amidst
another just-okay split sneaky has stood
still there's a lot of question marks
surrounding c9 going forward but there's
one thing we can likely count on sneaky
we'll hold down the ball lane for c9 and
he'll continue to be the cornerstone
that holds this iconic franchise
together I want to keep playing
professionally as long as I can I don't
think that's ever a stopping point so
I'm not gonna stop it five years from
now I'm just gonna keep on going because
there's nothing else I'd really do
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button